situation
je le le regain de de violence qu'il y a
là-bas c'est oui c'est c'est une des
raisons qui pousseent les communautés à
se à se taper dessus en France trop
régulièrement alors que très souvent
c'est pour des mauvaises raisons et et
pour des choses qui n'ont rien à voir
enfin ça concerne en tout cas des gens
qui ne connaissent pas ce qui se passe
là en fait à titre personnel oui les les
premières fois que j'ai entendu des
expressions
antisémites proche de moi ça a été au
moment de ce qui s'est passé en 2006 je
pense que ça va se reproduire on a déjà
vu des des propos des propos assez
ambigu là récemment je pense que ça va
pas ça va pas aller en s'arrangeant tant
qu'il y aura pas une issue concrète à ce
conflit là faut je pense que c'est
logiquement indubitable que dès que il
sera is répliquera violemment et ça ne
serurait tardé il y aura automatiquement
une explosion des banlieux voilà et je
et qu'il y aura il y aura beaucoup de
problèmes de sécurité en France ça me
paraît
logique